[Music]
brittany is with us in greensboro north
carolina hi brittany welcome to the
ramsay show
hi
um can you hear me sure what's up yeah
um my husband it wants to go back to
school
and we're working the baby steps and he
wants me to be open to loans student
loans
and i don't want to i do not want to do
that it absolutely terrifies me and i
don't know how to
still support him but stay on my ground
about not getting into it because we've
already been working the baby steps and
i want to keep
going forward in baby step two yeah
you're working the baby steps he's not
yeah yeah yeah
what's he want to study
he wants to go into school social work
you want to go into debt to do social
work
yeah
do you know what that pays
i i know i know
i don't want to pay that much money
in student loans to go into debt i don't
even want to pay that much money to be a
social worker they don't pay anything
what's he make now
he's at about 20 now he's a teacher
assistant
how old is he
he is 30. okay teacher assistant in a
public school and he wants to go into
social work
yes
uh you know i think dave's right i think
i would expand the options but certainly
social work is one path but there are
multiple paths to probably do what he
enjoys most about social work for
instance he probably has a heart for the
counseling side of it the helping the
advocating side does that sound about
right
that sounds right yeah
what college does he have any college
education so far
associates degree uh-huh
yeah i i gotta tell you uh finishing out
that the full degree because he's
already in the system and getting that
four-year degree finish would put him in
a position where he could potentially
move into some type of guidance
counselor role or something along those
lines but i think he's got to research
multiple options but getting that
student loan taking out loans to do a
degree to do social work it's just not
necessary because quite frankly he can
cash flow that i mean we teach that here
at ramsey solutions so if he buckles
down and is patient
right you guys got to get through the
baby steps at certain points or he's
going to have to work harder and he's
going to have to cash flow his way
through maybe a second job but he
doesn't need the loan and it's actually
a bad business it's not a good roi if
that's what he really wants to do
taking out a loan for that is is is
really a bad idea so brittany sometimes
when people
feel like they're stuck in a job
like he feels like he's stuck at this
public school in this resource role
right they they go oh what i need's a
degree
and that just pops into their head
because that's what we've been telling
people for a couple generations
and that's not necessarily a fact
what he needs is some clear direction on
what he wants to be
and what he wants to do exactly and then
determine if a degree is absolutely
necessary is there a way that he can
make 50 60 70 000 a year instead of 40
and not even have to get a degree to do
it
yes there is
and maybe be in an area where he's
serving
the underprivileged in some way which is
what his heart is and that's a good
heart and i'm not against social workers
don't misunderstand me but i i the
number of people i've talked to that
spent 200 000 bucks on a master's degree
in social work to make 38 000 worth of
state makes me want to shoot somebody
that's just cray-cray
and i over the years of doing this i've
just seen a lot of people they destroy
their lives because they didn't lay out
their dream in such a way that it didn't
become a nightmare
and so i'm going to send you a copy of
ken's brand new book the from paycheck
to purpose
tell him to read that
and then the other book i'm going to
give you is our book here called debt
free degree
on how to go get a degree debt free
time to read that if he's not willing to
read two books he doesn't need to go to
school
right because at school they're gonna
like require you to read books and stuff
yeah yeah yeah you catch the sarcasm
right
yes
i i've said several of the things you
all have said
all right you hold on kelly will pick up
and we'll ship those two
out to you but there's this mythical
thing it's not a genie in a bottle if
that's exactly what they they there
degree here comes the genie hey
you're three witches yes i grant you
your three wishes you now have a degree
you get to be whatever you want to be
before you weren't going to mount
anything but now you have got the genie
that's a good that's a good line well
it's it's really robin williams voice on
the disney cartoon oh that's so good and
so that's the cultural pressure folks
make sure you catch that that's what
we've been told we've been marketed to
since the 50s that that's the only way
to success it's like the lie that you
have to buy a house 20 seconds after
you're an adult yeah or you're yes
you're wasting you're wasting your money
you're throwing your money down throwing
your money out the window yeah and so
you're exactly right and that again one
of the major reasons why we wrote the
book uh from paycheck to purpose how do
i figure out what the mountaintop is
that's where this gentleman's at it
might be social work
but how do you go from it might be i
think it is to i know it is and that's
the stage one that we'd start with get
clear get clear does it align with how
i'm created does social work involve
skills that i actually have or some raw
talent that i can hone into skills do i
love the work that if you read a
description
under social work
would that make your heart come alive if
you spent 75 percent of your day doing
that then the final pieces mission
does it produce results does social work
or that type of work produce results
that fill your heart up with hey hey
this is significant to me that's the
ultimate test there and if the answer is
yes go for